you probably see a dollar bill every day
but have you ever really looked at one
what is all that stuff even mean let's
start with the easy stuff this is George
Washington in case you've never heard of
him he's labeled this particular picture
of our first president comes from a
never finished portrait by Gilbert
Stuart because of the engraving process
the image on the bill is reversed the
portrait is supported by bay laurel
leaves which are often used to represent
status you know think ancient Greece the
Louvre depicted here are still budding
possibly representing that the US has
yet to reach its full bloom this is the
Treasury seal featuring a mountains for
justice a key for trust and a sash with
13 stars remember that number 13 it
comes up again later over here are the
signatures of the treasurer of the
United States and the Secretary of the
Treasury this series date tells you what
year the design of that particular
dollar originated and this guy over here
is the Federal Reserve seal if you read
the ring around the seal you can see at
which of the 12 Federal Reserve Bank's
your bill was printed if you don't like
reading city names you can also just
look at the letter in the center each
Bank has its own unique letter it pause
this part if you're actually interested
you'll also notice that letter is the
first character in your serial number
alright let's flip it over to the side
which is officially considered the
reverse or back side of the bill in god
we trust' was adopted as the official
motto of the United States in 1956 those
two circles in the two halves of our
national seal and one is the number of
dollars at the piece of paper is worth
this is our national bird holding our
national shield the shoe looks like our
flag but it's missing the stars that
ribbon the Eagle is trying to eat says a
pluribus unum which is when four out of
many one the Eagle is holding an olive
branch and some arrows to represent that
while we're down with peace we are ready
for war at least he's looking at the
olive branch indicating that you know
all things being equal he would
definitely prefer peace the peace is
probably the dollar bills biggest WTF so
let's break it down piece by piece Novus
Ordo seclorum sounds like a Harry Potter
spell but is actually aligned from the
ancient Roman poet Virgil meaning a new
order of the ages a new except this
translates to he has favored our
undertaking Xand that's a he with a
capital H if you know what I mean
the pyramid represents strength and
durability and at the foot of the
pyramid are the Roman numerals for 1776
the year of the Declaration of
Independence there are 13 levels of the
pyramid representing the original 13
colonies those 13 colonies are
represented all over the bill including
13 arrows there
stars in the star thingy mom the eagle's
head also known as a glory 30 news on
the olive branch their King pearls
extending from either side of the seal
and there are more thirteen's if you
squint your eyes and look real hard for
instance both these lines have 13
letters if you count this thing is one
letter which let's do because I don't
know how to look it up the floating eye
is the Eye of Providence a symbol that
has been used throughout history to
represent God watching over us some
people including those who saw the
popular Nicholas Cage movie national
treasure will tell you that the eye is
the symbol of the Illuminati are the
Freemasons and represents their
influence in our government but for this
video let's just stick to the facts and
the fact is if you ask enough English
majors you can get an unfinished guide
pyramid on a barren landscape to
represent anything but then again over
here in the corner there appears to be
an owl so what do I know
all this symbolism on one little piece
of paper did you ever notice any of it